anytime innocent life is lost as tragic
and very sad muslims who are the true
followers of jesus moses and all of
god's prophets with muhammad is being
the final the last condemned these evil
acts and we should all condemn them
wherever they happen be it in Paris
Syria Palestine Burma all innocent life
is precious
now don't be selective in your
condemnation because it's not cool or
because you won't fit in if you condemn
one but not all innocent life is
precious we condemn it anytime it's lost
Muslims have a genuine altruism because
it's a basic teachings in Islam and we
would probably be the most upset when we
hear such sad news because Muslims have
the most to lose it's very disheartening
when you see ungentle and malevolent
people who are just looking to join any
hate parade coming out cursing
threatening just augmenting the fire
with their poisonous and toxic hate
these monovalent type of people are no
different and would do no different than
the terrorists themselves have given the
chance you hear them calling to kill all
Muslims vandalizing mosques houses of
worship where people go to worship and
peace attacking innocent Muslim women in
hijab these are those treacherous and
demonic human beings these are the real
terrorists who are just waiting to do
real terror against innocent Muslims
their threats and actions are loud but
no one seems to listen no one seems to
care or condemn most of these people who
spew this nasty toxic hate if you look
closely are very arrogant people who
already live very bitter and angry lives
probably wouldn't give a poor man even a
dime nor attenti any neighborly needs
nor do they care what corruption is
happening in their own backyard let
alone in Paris or in other part of the
world it's only when a hate parade is in
town via Facebook Twitter or just to
spew that poisonous hate at any chance
they get really think about how
depressing is that to live that kind of
hate filled life now let's compare that
to our role model
the prophet of mercy who was sent to all
of mankind who was consoled by the
Creator in the Koran because he was
almost killing himself out of love
worrying with grief because they had
denied the almighty the pure monotheism
of the maker of mankind whose message
was the same as Jesus and all of God's
prophets which was to proclaim God's
oneness and to set up no one else in
worship or have intermediaries next to
the crater of mankind the Quran is very
explicit and clear it tells us when an
innocent life is lost it's as though you
have killed all of mankind this is in
quran chapter 5 verse 32 but they say
look Isis they're shouting Allah Akbar
representing you and you guys are not
condemning it I said look my dear
brother what Rock you've been under or
hiding in we condemned it very loud and
very clear the problem is you just don't
want to hear it
you seem to fit the description of when
Jesus said though seeing they see not
though hearing they do not understand
how many times are we going to tell you
that this has nothing to do with Islam
how many Muslims and Muslim scholars
have we had just for instance on the
Deen show telling the world the same
thing but the media loves creating
sensationalism instead of giving us a
platform and a voice to educate they
instead help prop up and promote ISIL as
if they represent Islam that 0.01 fringe
element that even Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him had prophesized would come
he warned us Muslims about these ISIL
kill more Muslims if you didn't know
that - now the mainstream media they
don't dare give the spotlight nor
advertise them 24/7 wall to our coverage
groups such as sovereign state neo-nazis
or the KKK even though these groups are
making so much trouble and are the
greatest threat to America and national
security
you don't hear peep just ice so Isis all
day every day programming people day by
day as it said repeat a lie enough
and you'll get people to believe it and
that's what they do with their
monovalent so-called hade Islamic
experts who have more in common with
Isis and the KKK these hearts void a
mercy and love just joining any hate
parade we know that hundreds of
thousands of innocent people have died
just in a few years in Syria Palestine
Burma and the list goes on and innocent
people continue dying in these countries
each and every day look it up and see
what's going on but there is little
mention of it in the media or none at
all it's not good for business nor do
the American people know no wall-to-wall
coverage to let the world know of these
atrocities we also have college
university shootings mega killings here
each and every day but it's quick news
that quickly goes away except when it
has to do with Muslims and Islam then
it's 24 hours wall-to-wall coverage each
and every day never going away anytime
innocent life is lost it's an atrocity
that we all should condemn wherever it
may be I want to talk to those who call
themselves Muslim and remind them that
your prophet mohammad salallahu alayhi
wasalam who was a prophet for all of
mankind he warned you about going to
extreme for being extremely ignorant in
your Deen from abandoning salat prayer
from abandoning giving in church and
from being the best neighbor he told you
you can rise up to the highest levels of
Jenna by having the best manners in
character helping to change the world
for the better and not by spreading
corruption and hate he warned you from
going to extremes in your religion and
always to choose the middle path make
Toba to Allah but don't remain ignorant
or deem thinking you're going to get an
easy ride bringing that gangster stuff
and mentality into Islam you just made
Tobal hamdulillah you left off wine
strip clubs gambling and all immorality
but now you want to skip sitting at the
feet of the scholars and really learning
your Deen you read a few books became an
overnight share making your own [ __ ]
was young pumped up and naive you want
to go fight you think you're brave again
bringing that fake gangster man
tality into the Dean you can't even wake
up for fudger go and help clean up your
neighborhood connect with the people
share with them your food and their
right to know Islam be of the best of
manners and character try to make the
world a better place or at least keep
people safe from your harm for our
brothers and sisters in humanity please
don't fall for the false media hype and
don't be like ignorant fools or
harboring poisonous feelings infecting
people with toxic hate quoting Quranic
verses or hadith out of context with an
malevolent agenda you'll see when you
take a sincere even-handed approach that
these violent crimes against humanity
have nothing to do with Islam because
Islam condemns it again if you're
sincere and you want to know the truth
go ahead and do your research now why is
this happening you see this is a
geopolitical thing like when the
Catholic Christian RRA
the Irish Republican Army were just
killing and blowing everything up they
wanted political freedom from the United
Kingdom and viewed their land Ireland
was illegally invaded occupied and
illegitimately ruled by the British they
had a political grievance but did we
blame all of Christians for all the
terror they had imposed just because
someone screams Allahu Akbar god is
great before doing a crime doesn't make
them legit the same way the notorious
Pablo Escobar would cross himself up
with the Trinity before he murdered
terrorized and racelle killing thousands
of innocent people and others exactly
like him who might not scream god is
great but silently they were throwing up
the three point cross as and hroub relic
and the Crusaders did so again we don't
blame all Christianity because the
actions of the KKK nor all us Americans
because of an atomic bomb nor all Jews
because of the radical extreme Zionists
who are perpetrating terrorism and
anti-semitism against Palestinians who
are cementec to remember terrorism has
no faith and knows no boundaries Jews
Christians and Muslims all people of
other faiths need to work together
collaborate together in goodness to
create an atmosphere of understanding
and love and not
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below